[Music]
from 2016 to 2019
meteorologists saw record-breaking heat
waves around the globe
rampant wildfires in california and
australia
and the longest run of category 5
tropical cyclones on record
the number of extreme weather events has
been increasing for the last 40 years
and current predictions suggest that
trend will continue
but are these natural disasters simply
bad weather
or are they due to our changing climate
to answer this question we need to
understand the differences between
weather and climate what they are how we
predict them
and what those predictions can tell us
meteorologists define
weather as the conditions of the
atmosphere at a particular time
and place currently researchers can
predict a region's weather for the next
week
with roughly eighty percent accuracy
climate
describes a region's average atmospheric
conditions
over periods of a month or more
climate predictions can forecast average
temperatures for decades
to come but they can't tell us what
specific weather events to expect
these two types of predictions give us
such different information
because they're based on different data
to forecast weather
meteorologists need to measure the
atmosphere's initial conditions
these are the current levels of
precipitation
air pressure humidity wind speed and
wind direction
that determine a region's weather twice
every day
meteorologists from over 800 stations
around the globe
release balloons into the atmosphere
these balloons
carry instruments called radiosondes
which measure initial conditions and
transmit their findings to international
weather centers
meteorologists then run the data through
predictive physics models that generate
the final weather forecast
unfortunately there's something stopping
this global web of data from producing
a perfect prediction weather is a
fundamentally
chaotic system this means it's
incredibly sensitive
and impossible to perfectly forecast
without absolute knowledge of all the
systems
elements in a period of just 10 days
even incredibly small disturbances can
massively impact
atmospheric conditions making it
impossible to reliably predict weather
beyond two weeks climate prediction on
the other hand is far
less turbulent this is partly because a
region's climate is by definition
the average of all its weather data but
also
because climate forecasts ignore what's
currently happening in the
atmosphere and focus on the range of
what could happen
these parameters are known as boundary
conditions
and as their name suggests they act as
constraints
on climate and weather one example of a
boundary condition
is solar radiation by analyzing the
precise distance and angle between
a location and the sun we can determine
the amount of heat
that area will receive and since we know
how the sun behaves
throughout the year we can accurately
predict its effects on temperature
averaged across years of data this
reveals periodic patterns
including seasons most boundary
conditions have well-defined values that
change slowly
if at all this allows researchers to
reliably predict climate
years into the future but here's where
it gets tricky
even the slightest change in these
boundary conditions represents a much
larger shift for the chaotic weather
system for example
earth's surface temperature has warmed
by almost one degree celsius over the
last 150 years
this might seem like a minor shift but
this one degree change
has added the energy equivalent of
roughly one million
nuclear warheads into the atmosphere
this massive surge of energy has already
led to a dramatic
increase in the number of heat waves
droughts and storm surges
so is the increase in extreme weather
due to random chance
or changing climate the answer is that
while weather will always be
a chaotic system shifts in our climate
do
increase the likelihood of extreme
weather events
scientists are in near universal
agreement that our climate is changing
and that human activity is accelerating
those changes
but fortunately we can identify what
human behaviors are
impacting the climate most by tracking
which boundary conditions
are shifting so even though next month's
weather might always be
a mystery we can work together to
protect
the climate for centuries to come
so what kind of solutions to the climate
crisis are people working on
how about underwater farming certain
crops could actually help clean the
oceans while drawing carbon down from
the atmosphere
or how about new energy sources here's
what a world run
entirely on renewable energy sources
would look like